ok go go pour la mission fruits on voit
toutes les semaines nous à l'épicerie
pour aller faire des recherches tels que
l'alimentation pour moi ça fait partie
de mon programme éducatif
christine est propriétaire d'une
garderie en milieu familial à
havre-saint-pierre ville de 3500
habitants sur la côte nord les frais
sont les frais
l'épicerie ici on a juste une puis on
n'a pas le choix de bannières de ce
qu'il faut pour remplir son garde manger
comme partout le sait sauf que la
qualité et le prix si différentes
pour faire quoi quant à eux terminé nos
achats
parfois elle est tentée d'aller faire
ses courses dans une autre ville il est
loin de même si loulou je sais qu'il ya
des ajouts intéressants que je peux
faire
comparativement à issy les ouvre le
mexique est à sept-îles c'est quoi
sert-elle par rapport à ici les 222 km
fait que dans le fond sur michel aulas
et y vivre dans une région à faible
densité de population nécessite une
bonne dose d'imagination et de
planification avant de passer à table
ce que j'ai compris c'est que tu peux
pas te lever le matin viser aujourd'hui
plus je décide de faire à manger tout
des fois on se fait des pentes et on se
fait ch aux aspects des t-bonds je peux
pas faire ce pas ce que ça va me coûter
beaucoup plus cher parce que s'ils
cherchent ils pas ici j'ai pas une bonne
offre un endroit je voyage je vois voir
ce que je veux ou finale mais ici c'est
pas comme ça avec les années christine a
développé ses stratégies pour économiser
la salle à faire ces petits roquets du
costco ou votre conjoint québec après
déjà deux tons la whey fido d'un auteur
bas et c'est tout le compost qu'on a
fait avec les enfants elle initie aussi
les enfants de ces garderies à la
culture de légumes fait que vu qu'on
avait à combler les espaces avec les
tomates dans le même type de requête sic
encore une super belle fille donc le
retour à la terre fait partie de la
solution
faut comprendre qu initialement les gens
trouvaient ça un peu fou de venir faire
d'agriculture ici à même bande
localement les jantes est loin d'être
convaincu ses pions on peut on peut
comprendre
josée bélanger est une des fondatrices
du grenier boréale une coopérative
fondée en 2013
ici à la pointe de mende à son pari
faire pousser fruits et légumes dans un
environnement peu propice à
l'agriculture
voilà merci tout aussi s'y met avec
beaucoup d'efforts on n'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas naturel comme ont su le
québec gérer qui pose bien ici le
vraiment seul irradie les navets
échouent les chouquettes on a des
tomates la déco comme toutes les choses
de chaleur on est capable quand même
d'enfants
on a cette préoccupation là nous de
favoriser l'accès en proximité on
s'assure d'être dans une moyenne de prix
le plus corrects possibles pour que les
gens puissent y accéder en fait le
grenier boréale est un bel exemple de la
prise en charge d'une communauté et
l'impact va au delà de l'agriculture les
gens redécouvrent en fait ce qu'il
faisait à petite échelle dans une
perspective plus de subsistance les
années antérieures cultivés localement
puis d'avoir accès à des produits bons à
l'issue de leurs efforts
nous aussi nous un rôle à jouer comme
coopérative le vandale le fait que bon
la nutrition c'est une question aussi
qui permet d'améliorer la santé etc
et l'éducation fait partie aussi du
mandat du grenier boréale on a participé
à l'installation d'une serre l'oci à
l'école ici au village à longue pointe
de mingan
ça permet aux enfants en fait de
découvrir que les légumes viennent pas
dans ses rangs drap le grenier boréal a
aussi donné un coup de pouce à la
création de cette serre à la co-op les
choix de marguerite à baie johan beetz
ce sont ses résidents qu'ils devaient
auparavant faire 120 kilomètres pour
acheter leur lait et qui se sont
regroupées pour mettre sur pied ce
coopérative en fait l'épicerie roule
depuis 2011
la solution c'était vraiment de partir
une coopérative qui donnait des services
de proximité ça prend un investissement
de tous les habitants pour que ça
fonctionne en co-op comme ça oui c'est
sûr on a quand même plus de 300 membres
puis on est juste c'est sa moins de 100
habitants donc il ya beaucoup de gens
qui pensent et qui trouve ça merveilleux
qui achètent leur carte de membre
[Musique]
le matin de notre passage les bénévoles
s'activent à regarnir le petit commerce
donc ce département le plus compliqué
parce que les fruits et légumes avec le
transport c'est pas évident des fois il
y arrive un petit peu amoché d'où
l'importance de notre deuxième volet
c'est lassant donc ça nous permet du
moins pendant l'été d'avoir des produits
plus frais les gens se sont habitués à
aller à l'extérieur faire leurs
commissions faire leur épicerie
donc au début ça a été le défi de
ramener les gens à venir faire leur
épicerie ici c'est de faire comprendre
aux gens que ce n'est pas indépendant
ans et une épicerie conquiert est
important que les gens qui vivent avec
johan beetz soient conscients de ce qui
s approvisionnent principalement chez
nous l'implication de julie et des
membres de la coopérative fait partie de
la solution à l'insécurité alimentaire
mais malgré tous ses efforts le prix du
panier d'épicerie coûtera encore de 15 à
20% plus cher que dans les grands
centres
et la situation n'est pas unique à cette
région des décisions politiques devront
être prises pour assurer la sécurité
alimentaire de tous les québécois
[Musique]